[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIONNA GLAZE: Hi.
Thanks for sharing your
lunch time with me.
I'm going to tell you
about this cool stuff
that we're working on,
after I tell you why.
So some potential customers
have shared with us
that there are some barriers
for them moving their workloads
to a cloud instead of on Prem.
And the biggest three
factors are regulation,
trust in companies,
and compromise,
and what can happen
to the data that
is on other people's machines.
I'm not going to talk too
much about regulation.
Here we go.
It's the other button.
But I will tell you how
we aim to solve problems
with trust and compromise with
our open source framework.
All right, so by trust, I mean
you are running your software
on other people's
machines, and they
can be running
arbitrary software
to manage those machines,
and they can, unfortunately,
sometimes get compromised.
Not saying that
happens at Google.
Now, beyond just
the companies, there
can be individual
administrators who
have access to these computers
so that they can do their jobs.
And they can be compromised
in one way or the other
through phishing, or
they're overtly malicious.
Now, the compromised
component is,
when you're running
on these computers,
they can be subject to problems
in, like, the Linux kernel.
Everybody running on Linux is
open to these same problems.
There is also being able to
break out of the DMA jail
from rogue peripherals,
and to just go grab--
go snooping memory.
And that's not so great.
So when data is
accessible on a machine,
it is also subject
to a legal discovery.
So we consider that, also,
as part of compromise factors
for confidential data.
So enclaves are two
things in the abstract.
They are isolation for
your execution and data,
and they are attestation.
I want to tell you a little
bit about what that means.
So isolation is that the
operating system, the BIOS,
hardware other than the CPU,
is all outside of your trust
boundary.
It is not able to see
any of your memory
or tamper with your
execution at all.
In a typical process, the OS has
full control over your process.
The BIOS can be tampered with.
The hardware can have
access beyond what you want.
Right, and when this data is
not even available to the kernel
and is only available
to your enclave,
it is not subject
to legal discovery.
The second component of
an enclave is attestation.
And attestation aims
to answer the question,
with cryptographic guarantees,
that the software you're
talking to is really the
software that you want
to be talking to, and that
it is running on the hardware
that you expect to be giving
you these Trusted Execution
Environment guarantees.
When you put these
two things together,
you're able to make the
following statement, that you
send secrets only
to your software,
and only your software
can read them.
And that's really important to
a lot of potential customers
who want to move to Cloud,
for a lot of reasons.
OK, so isolation, attestation
are nice properties
to say that an enclave
is in the abstract,
but unfortunately, that is
not an industry standard.
And there are a
lot of technologies
that market themselves as
enclaves or Trusted Execution
Environments that don't give
all aspects of isolation
and attestation
that we really want.
And because it's
too early to know
which one of these
technologies is really
going to win in the
marketplace, it's
nice to have your enclave
applications be written
for an abstract
notion of an enclave,
so that you can move around.
And that's what Asylo is.
Right?
It is a framework that abstracts
over enclave technology
and notions of attestation
so that you can easily
migrate between different
Trusted Execution back ends.
And now, a really,
really awesome cool thing
that is in Asylo is support
for a POSIX-based programming.
Now, when you're in one of these
Trusted Execution Environments,
you have that the OS is outside
of your trusted computing
base, which means that
you don't get to use it,
which means it's really
hard to write software
in the typical way that
people usually write software.
And now to talk a bit more
about how the POSIX system works
in Asylo, I want to introduce
my colleague, Chong Cai.
CHONG CAI: I'm going to briefly
talk about the POSIX support
that Asylo provides.
So, as Dionna talked
about earlier, when you're
inside an enclave, it
provides security isolation
even from the operating system.
So we're having trouble for
code running inside enclave
to access the resources
that's usually provided
by the operating system.
So Asylo provides a POSIX layer
to make user code get access
to them.
The way, so which includes
how to access clock,
IO like readwrite, and
other kinds of syscalls
that you normally
want to access.
We implement them with
security features added.
So normally, when an
application makes a syscall,
it access the operating
system for the operation.
But in enclave
case, code running
is enclave is isolated
from the operating system.
So that's not the option.
And we provide, Aslyo
provides a POSIX layer,
which is an API level
of implementation
for the syscalls.
So the user code that's
running inside an enclave
does not need to
know, OK, this code
is running inside
the enclave, I need
to access the Asylo POSIX API.
They can just access
exactly the syscall as user.
And Asylo POSIX layer would run
that syscall and in some cases,
it exits the enclave
and delegates
the syscall to the operating
system with security features
added.
The goal for Asylo
POSIX layer is
to provide exactly the same
behavior as if it's on a host.
The user code does
not need to know it's
running inside the enclave.
They say they can call exactly
the same syscall as they would
on the host, and
they should expect
exactly the same behavior.
The way we do that
is, for example,
for non-sensitive operations,
it may just exit the enclave
and delegate the
call to the host.
And there are some other
interesting examples
that we provide to
achieve this goal.
For example, signals.
When somebody registers a
handler inside an enclave,
the Asylo POSIX layer saves
that handler inside the enclave,
then it exits the enclave,
register a handler on a host.
When that signal arrives,
the handler on the host
is invoked, which
invokes an entry
point to enter the
enclave and invoke
the corresponding handler that's
registering inside the enclave.
So the user can expect
the same behavior
they register handler
inside the enclave
and when the signal arrives,
their handlers should be
[INAUDIBLE].
Another interesting
example is a fork.
Fork is a syscall
that limits users
to create a process that's
exact the same as a parent.
However, enclaves are not
clonable for security reason.
So, in order to support
that, we provide
duplication and encryption
of the enclave states.
So we load a new enclave.
We encrypt the old
enclave data and restore
that in the new enclave.
The security features for fork
is not fully implemented yet.
We're working actively
to support secure fork.
And even though we are
providing security features
for the syscalls
that we provide,
sometimes it's not impossible
to make it fully secure.
On our website
aslylo.dev, we have
documentations fully detailed
of syscalls we provide.
And if there is any possible
security concern or issues
it may have, the user code
should investigate into that
before they make syscalls.
And so what do we have support
right now for Asylo POSIX
layer, is we have provide
enough POSIX layer support
to run a fully featured GRPC.
We can also run a full feature
latest open source Redis.
I will do a quick demo later
to show how we can do that.
And in both cases, we don't
need to make any source change
to either of them.
We can just to pull exactly
the same code from the GitHub
and run that inside
an enclave with Asylo.
So you're welcome to check
out our website aslylo.dev
if you're interested for updates
and documentations for Asylo.
And our open source project
is at github.com/google/asylo.
Can check it out if
you're interested.
And I'm going to do a quick
demo to show how you can
run Redis inside an enclave.
So what do you need to
run and use application
like Redis inside an
enclave is a workspace.
So first you need
a workspace file.
Sorry, the color is probably
a little bit hard to read.
So, right here, you
want to import--
somehow it's not
showing the whole thing.
But you want to import
Asylo right here.
Asylo.3.4 is the latest
release that we have.
And, of course, you
want to import Redis,
if that's the use application
you want to be build.
The latest open source,
which is Redis 5.0.4.
Asylo provides a build
file in Asylo code base
that builds Redis with Bazel,
which is the Google build tool.
And, other than that, you
need a dot Bazel RC file.
This basically tells
Bazel what tool chain,
what cross tool to use, and
what the build configs are.
This is exactly the same file
copied from Asylo GitHub.
We don't need to
make any changes.
Finally, the last thing
you need is a build target
to tell Bazel what
do you want to build.
So here we provide an
application wrapper,
which wraps the
user main function
entrance in the trusted part
of the code, the raw method.
So the only thing
we needed is to wrap
that in cc enclave binary, which
is our application wrapper.
You give it a name.
And you put what you want
to build as a build target
in the dependencies.
So here Redis main is a target
that runs the Redis server.
So that's everything you need.
Now, we can just build
application wrapper.
So Bazel is the
Google build tool.
So we give it a config,
which is enc sim.
Tells it to build the targets
in simulated environment.
And Asylo Redis is the target
that we just add for cc enclave
binary.
Here it is.
You can see that it
builds very quickly.
It's speakers I
have configured it
because we don't have enough
time to build it right here.
OK, so once you
have it built, we
are ready to run the binary,
which is placed in the Bazel
bin, and this is the
binary we just built.
And we run a binary, we can see
that Redis server is running,
is up.
It's running inside the enclave.
Here we have a warning
about current maximum
open file is 1,024.
That's because this is
the current maximum file
descriptors we allow with
Asylo inside an enclave.
And so now it's ready
to accept connections.
So in a different terminal,
we run Redis client
to connect to the server.
We can pin it and we can set
whatever key and a value.
And I'll get it just to like
normally you would use Redis.
OK, that's everything
I have for the demo.
Is there any questions?
SPEAKER: Thank you, Chong.
CHONG CAI: Thank you.